η απόφαση μου να δημουργήσω την μμετοκαμή ο σύζεται σε αυτό το γεγονός σχέφτηκα ότι
δεν μπορούμε να μείνουμε χωρίς φάρμακα και αυτόμε οδήγησε στη δημιουργία της εταιρίας ύθελα να
κάνουν κάτι εακόσμιο και ξεκινήσαμε αμε αμέσως με εξαγορίαυπουργίία στην αρχήήτα εντελωσαμε τοχι δε τους
ένειας πουλί υτότο πράγμα σας κυρι πισας έγινε ποτε πρόταση να υπουρκοποιθείται χθς ναι θεωρείτε
πως το κόμμα ο δημοκρατικός συναγερμός τοθα ξεπεράσει σύντομα την κρίσει που βρίσκεται κατακαιρούς ο
συναερμός κατακάποιο τρόπο συμέρχεται η προερώ τώα είναι αρκετά ταλατούχα το σύθυμα είαι να τοπω
αγκλικάς κάιδλίμε της νομίζω ότι θα συδυχήσουμε ε το ίδιο τρόπο όταν υπράξι μιαανταπόκριση από
τη κυβέληση τότ θατεολες και φίλη άλλο έναντεέναλλά ευπότκα σήμερα μαζί σας η διαίτερη τιμή
και χαρά γιατί σήμερα εδώ στο στούτιο το αντέναλά ευπότας είναι ο δόχτορ αντρέας πίας
ιδριτή κα εκτελεστικός πρόεδρος της μετοχεμή ο οποίος μιλάσπάνεια έχει πολλά ναπι και είναι και
το πρώτο πότκαςστο οποίο βγαίνει και για αυτό είναι και η διαϊτερητιμή και επίτ ευχαριστό
πολύ που απόδεκθηκα την πρόσκληση να ιστε στο πόταστο αντέναμδεν σε καλάτο ξεκινούμεε τοχή για
έχώσε ευδομη τα έξι λοπικαι τώρα μας σας να διμιουργήσετε τη φαρμακευτική σας αυτοκρατορία τ
ήταν αυτό που σας ώθησε